the view under fire for fueling this
ridiculous conspiracy theory about the
first lady watch I wasn't gonna go along
with this but that one in that picture
doesn't like know you weren't gonna go
now you will know it's a different
shaped face I'm ashamed to say I spent
like an hour on Saturday involved in
this that's Melania is not a very tall
statuesque woman and the one that we saw
the first one that we showed she she
looks kind of short not this one but
that one
well look how short she looks could be
in flats
her husband's like six seven and a
staple genius president Trump slamming
those body double rumors by tweeting
quote the fake news photoshopped
pictures of Melania then propelled
conspiracy theories that it's actually
not her by my side in Alabama and other
places they are only getting more
deranged with time a spokeswoman for the
first lady is blasting the show as
shameful so Jessie let's say it's true
let's say it is a fake Melania wouldn't
you love to have a fake Jessie this I
kind of do agree with joy can we put the
screen back up there I mean put the
screen back up there there is something
very suspicious Melania of Melania if
you look at if you look at the mouth
there's a difference in the mouth and
and there's a little bit hear me out on
this there's a little bit of a height
difference Caitlyn Jenner no I think
what it is is is that Melania you don't
need a body double if you're Melania if
you're if you're a model there's no such
thing as a body double for a model it's
just called another model I mean like
you know if there was an actual body
double for Melania she'd be much more
famous and have a much better job than
being a body double for milania's trade
arrangement so Jim remember remember the
other conspiracies we remember that
Trump was going to hand the reins over
to pence and the Trump is a puppet of
Putin or that it wasn't his real hair
that Hillary were having a dalliance
during the week did bill know of course
actually true mister not Katie what is
the subtext here that the first lady has
pieced out and that she actually is on
permanence of hearts and that she can't
stand being around the president cuz
he's so horrible and for that he should
be impeached it's just really stupid I
mean she can't catch a break right so if
she wasn't doing all these initiatives
she's doing on her own as her own person
building her own thing they would she
would you be accused of just being a
separate wife right and just doing
whatever President Trump wanted her to
do because she doesn't have a brain and
can't function on her own she goes out
on her own and proves that she's her own
person she's done all these trips she's
gotten overseas she's capable of talking
and speaking and and and pushing the
things that she wants to talk about and
then they still criticize her so I think
it's just petty there are other things
that they could be talking about and I
find it really interesting that the
women who are always saying you know the
women who don't help women are going to
hell decided to engage in this kind of
behavior no one is in Katie right leave
her alone yes I'll tell that to
President Trump he's the one tweeting
out about this and raising it it seems
to me he's not defending his wife he's
defending himself against the charge
that he has a double for his wife
because as you suggest maybe like her I
don't see it's insulting to me this is
like you know kind of conspiracy theory
wackiness and distraction from the
reality let's say how about the vote in
which Republicans will say hey you know
what that's that wall that emergency
bogus Gregg okay you know I was actually
what bugged me where people were making
jokes about the picture different jokes
about how how humorless and unfun they
look together without pointing out that
they were actually at a really saw
per event they were there too because
yeah of a natural disaster I but I have
to you have to be fair conspiracies are
bad on both sides and Minh you become a
team sport political player you get into
this little prison of two ideas and so
your immunity to conspiracies goes away
because you want to believe so right now
what you're seeing is a lowered immunity
among among the view because they hate
this guy so much that this has to be an
impostor but likewise we have had our
share of these kinds of conspiracies
because we had such deep dislike for the
other side so we never did see the
president's transcript what if the
long-form what a press releases his
grades as an olive branch to the
presidential releases his tax returns
would you accept that not a fair deal
I'm not going to take it I think we're
gonna be able to find the transcripts
without having to give the tax okay last
question what did he lock her up did he
lock is that a body double now this is
where the conversation goes in times
when people want to ignore real news I
tell you no Juan Williams just a sage